welcome to there be spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to John wick chapter three para
bellum is finally here and the brand new
film in the franchise has a hell of a
lot to unpack from it throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the movie as
well as giving my thoughts on it this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the phone yet and don't want to
have anything about it ruined then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I'm your host definition
thank you for clicking this video and I
just want to give a huge shout out to
slash a fan for their support from day
one and whether you've been here since
the beginning or have just joined it
means a lot to have so many people
checking out the content so I hope you
enjoyed the video now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of John wick
3 the third film in the franchise picks
up immediately after John wick 2 with
the titular character trying to escape
the streets of New York after gunning
down a member of the high table wick has
been made excommunicate oh and to make
matters worse he now has a 14 million
dollar bounty on his head
instantly this feels like a huge step up
from the prior films with the world's
top-ranked assassins now after the
character and he truly feels like he's
met his match a lot throughout after
escaping New York through a reconnection
to his past and trading in a ticket for
safe passage to Casablanca wick sets off
on a journey to gain penance from the
one who sits above the high table known
simply as the elder meanwhile in New
York and adjudicator of the table has
been revisiting those that helped wick
in the prior film and has instructed all
of them to vacate their positions within
one week amongst these are Winston
played by ian mcshane and the Barry King
played by Laurence Fishburne both of
these refused initially and I'll lay a
scorn which plays heavily into the
ending of the film this is because the
adjudicator has hired a man known as
zero who sees himself as an equal to
John zero has been put in place to deal
out punishment to those who dissent from
the table and this puts Winston and the
Barry King had odds with them back in
Casablanca wick meets up with Sophie
Eyre played by Halle Berry who owes the
character
Macha after he successfully managed to
get her daughter away from the dangerous
like that they leave together the two
discovered the location of the elder in
what is probably the best ever dogfight
put to film and another clear indicated
that in this universe you definitely
shouldn't hurt animals after meeting
with the elder John is told that his
excommunicated States will be lifted if
he returns to the Continental and kills
Winston however he will have to remain a
hitman and will be unable to return to a
life without death upon arriving at the
Continental John agrees to join Winston
in a war against the high table and the
location doubles into a war zone after
its deconsecrated and is no longer
listed as a business zone this finale is
outstanding and I was blown away seeing
some of my favorite characters from the
right franchise getting their own fight
scenes again Swick in what is some
phenomenal kung fu action eventually
wick defeats all of the adjudicative
forces including zero and a parlay is
called in light of the destruction that
has been caused now going into this film
I'm as I'm sure many just assume that
this was the last in the franchise with
this being the closing chapter of the
story that would in its wake leave room
for the new TV show the continent told
to take its place
however the movie takes a swift turn in
the last 10 minutes and sets up another
film in light of the parlay Winston is
told by the adjudicator that his powers
and the Continental ownership will be
reinstated if he stops the war this is a
pretty attractive deal for the character
who simply doesn't have the numbers to
fight wave after wave of high table
forces and thus he accepts there's still
one loose end though and that comes in
the form of John and Winston realizes
that he has to kill the character or at
least appear to Winston shoots wick off
the Continental which seemingly kills
him you can't keep this guy down though
and after his body cannot be found we
cut to wick being wheeled to the Bowery
King who still sits on top of his throne
the character is still covered in the
cuts at the high table dished out
earlier and it's clear he wants revenge
together the two make a pact to take
down the high table once and for all and
it's an amazing setup for the next film
and the franchise which will no doubt
see neo and Morpheus teaming up again
now throughout the film you get the
feeling that Winston was trying to
manipulate the odds in his favor and
that he had
some control over wicks fate unlikely
guess that he would survive the fall
similar to wick he really wants to get
rid of the high table ads too many
characters in the film including the
director who raised wick as a child with
New York joined together as a force they
would provide an army that could
actually stand against the high table
and there are drop lines throughout the
film about how New York would go to war
with the group so can definitely see
this happening the Continental TV series
in my eyes would be the perfect vehicle
to recruit and introduce all the gangs
and whilst Ian McShane is stated that he
won't be appearing in the show Reeves
himself has agreed to be a part of it
thus this could allow time for us to
learn about all the aspects of the city
as well as see the army slowly being
built that will take down the table I
really can't wait to see what they dish
up and hopefully this is the direction
that they take as I can see it making a
brilliant show if that's the route they
travel down and now on to my review John
wick just keeps getting better and
better and chapter 3 is another
outstanding action movie from start to
finish this really packs the delectable
death humour that you've come to expect
from the franchise and there were
several times I laughed out loud at just
how over-the-top the action was the
choreography on display here is
outstanding and every moment feels like
ballet playing out with guns each
character does a great job of lacing
each line of dialogue with subtext and
beat for beat this is probably the best
film in the franchise if not a close
second now if you didn't like the first
two films that you're not gonna like
this but what the hell is wrong with you
these are some of the best action movies
of our generation and chapter three ties
the bow on what it's an amazing trilogy
from start to finish
John wick chapter 3 gets a 9 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
and John wick 3 and if you feel like you
still want to see more going forward
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full plot
League breakdown video on the finale of
Game of Thrones which would be linked at
the end you've also just launched a
merch section on the channel so if you
want to help support the videos and get
something out of it make sure you click
the boxes in the description
below this is the channel for people who
were mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]